very few stars can sing dance and handle
comedy as adroitly as they can drum but
among those of us who can here's a young
lady who is so much a film directors
dream she's been asked to present the
award for best directing miss Shirley
MacLaine
surely how nice to see you thank you
very much
do you realize that the only time we get
together is once a year here at the
academy yes that's true well why don't
we exchange phone numbers so that we can
get together in between whatever for Bob
how can we improve on the arrangement we
already have
I'm fortunate enough to have had some of
the best directors in the most and the
world's most creative men so therefore
I'm quite proud and happy to present the
award for the best achievement in
directing the nominees are William Wyler
for the collector John Schlesinger
for darling David Lean dr. Zhivago
Robert wises for The Sound of Music and
hero she Toshiba Hara for woman in the
dunes
the winner is Robert wises sound cool
oh it gives me the greatest pleasure in
the world to accept this for Robert
wises I know he's heartbroken not to be
here this evening unfortunately he's
busy filming in Hong Kong but on his
behalf thank you very very much indeed